yeah whatever video folks
uh meanwhile awesome
I'm your host for today's evening
awesome awesome thank you so much guys
so we'll be starting the career master
class uh and we'll be talking about how
you can kick start your career in 2023
uh and digital marketing career like a
pro and we'll be talking about the
ultimate players roadmap okay so I would
love to know where you folks are from
meanwhile folks are joining in so I'll
just introduce myself here
uh my name is Russia and I'm your host
and I am from Bangalore India I am just
typing it over over chart because I
would love to chat with you guys
before we start
so I'm from Bangalore India and I would
love to know where you folks are from
you can just type it over chat here
welcome everyone uh folks who are just
joining now just to let you know we're
starting in few minutes
meanwhile uh you guys can just uh talk
over chat and let us know where you're
from so we'll get to know each other
better
okay I can see someone has asked
mashaban has asked can we get recording
of of this particular webinar yes you
will get it uh post webinar uh on a mail
and you can view it in case you know you
want to go through it again
I can see folks have started introducing
themselves on chat here I can see folks
who have joined from Mumbai I can see
sudarshan has joined from Mumbai I can
see modise has joined from Botswana
I can see mushroom has joined from Tamil
Nadu kalyani where have you joined us
from
I can see Renee from South Africa
good to have you here
hi uh before we start the session uh
let's just wait for some more time and
information will start the session
so today we are going to talk about
career master class on digital marketing
program uh by Purdy University meanwhile
I can see the introductions are still
going on on chat I can see bhumika from
Rajasthan
please do introduce yourself on chat
here
uh so uh speaker is joining in just few
minutes uh there is a little delay uh so
meanwhile Audrey can do it so I can see
that people have started talking on chat
here and I can see more introductions
coming in so just to let you know folks
who have just joined a little league uh
that we'll be talking about the career
masterclass and uh in digital marketing
by Purdue University and today we are
going to talk about the career roadmap
as well so if you have any questions
what you can do is you can put your
questions in the Q a section uh of here
or either you have joined from your
laptop or mobile
and also
yeah uh if we are putting questions on
the chart here so sorry we might miss it
because we get a lot of messages on chat
so meanwhile what we can do is if you
have questions about digital marketing
if you're confused about it if you want
to know more about the Purdue University
course if you want to know uh if you are
an experienced person if you are a
fresher like what kind of questions you
know you might have and we'll be taking
those questions uh during the webinar so
what you can do is you can go and put
your questions with your name let's
utilize this time and also new folks who
are joining in we are just starting in
few minutes
foreign
chat here so I would love to know where
you folks are from so I am from
Bangalore India
my name is Russia and I'm your host
today
before we start uh I would love to know
uh as I can see folks have joined from
different different uh parts of the
world
where are you folks from oh
I can see bernardite uh speaker has
already joined us so uh hi Benedict uh
let us start the session
hi excellent
uh
yes you are audible can you hear me
hello
can you hear me we can just just
hi uh
yes I can hear you just fine okay
awesome awesome
how are you doing I'm doing well awesome
I was saying let's start the career
master class uh so uh we can see a lot
of folks have joined from different
different parts of the world and uh
while you were uh not here like you know
while you're joining they actually were
introducing themselves and telling us
where they are from so uh that's really
amazing good afternoon where are you
from
um I'm originally from Texas but I am
here uh about 20 minutes outside of the
Atlanta area
okay awesome awesome uh welcome and uh
so we today we are going to talk about
how folks can uh kick-start their career
in digital marketing like a pro and also
we'll be talking about the ultimate
career roadmap you know they can shine
in just marketing uh with Purdue
University
okay very well
uh we have few ground rules uh so folks
if you have any questions you can put it
in the Q a box if you're joined from
your laptop uh from your mobile you will
see a q a box just beside your chat and
you can just post your questions there
uh in case you're putting questions down
in the chat I'm so sorry we actually get
a lot of messages on chat and uh we
really might miss out on the question
you have asked so we'll be taking the
questions uh throughout the session uh
so please have some patience for that
and also I saw like folks are asking if
they'll be getting a recording of this
session uh yes you will receive a
recording link of the session post
webinar uh over your mail and you can
view that recording in case you were to
go through it once again and also uh you
can also expect a follow-up email with
the recording link and also there's a
bonus offer you know in the in as well
so
let's move on uh so while I I saw that
you guys were giving your introductions
where you're from but I would love to
know how many years of experience do you
folks have so let's get to know each
other better uh so if you can see a poll
on your screen uh if you're currently
studying you can choose that option you
can if you are a fresher you have only
zero to three years of experience you
can choose that option if you're a
mid-level professional you can choose a
third option of three to five years and
if you have more than five years of
experience you can choose the fourth one
and just submit it that it's that easy I
can see folks have already started
voting uh for other few folks who are
left I would really suggest to just go
and vote for the correct option it's a
very easy peasy thing like how much
experience do you have you can see those
four questions on your screen right now
okay I'm gonna give like 10 seconds more
uh to the folks here
and I'm going to end that quote
okay I can see uh half of the folks uh
are actually uh professors or you know
have zero to three years of experience
and I can see folks who have uh between
like six to ten years of experience and
I can see uh most of them are working
professionals uh so great thank you so
much
before we move on uh to the career
Master Class
I would like you to introduce you to
bernary Chambers who has joined us here
to take us to the Purdue University
program of digital marketing uh could
you guys give us a good introduction
about yourself and so the audience can
get to know you better
yeah absolutely so uh welcome guys
thanks so much again for joining
um just a little bit blurb I'm not going
to spend a whole lot of time because I'm
pretty sure you want to get into the
meat and potatoes of the training but
um I started with simply learn back in
2017 as one of their junior level
trainers worked my way up to one of
their senior level trainers uh so I've
been with them quite some time I started
my expertise in social media management
back in 2013 and basically self-taught
using the actual platform data and the
platform courses to enable myself I have
about 11 years total
um with sales marketing customer service
but with the primary focus on digital
marketing so as these channels have
evolved um I have evolved with them I
have watched so many changes happen
across platforms and I'm seeing a bunch
of questions about all these different
things like chat GPT and all of that I
was here prior to any of that
um any of those developments and
technology so uh I launched my agency
around that time uh it was a 2012 exact
when I launched my agency and all we did
was social media and now we do paid
marketing we do SEO we build websites we
do a number of different things but
primary focus is in paid media so that's
just a little blurb about me and I will
give it back to our hosts
uh thank you so much uh birthday uh
welcome again uh so we are going to just
talk about today's agenda uh so we'll be
talking about digital marketing careers
and what this program offers and uh how
this program will actually get your job
ready and also we'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps and the Q a
section so don't forget the Q a section
you can always go and add your questions
in the Q a box uh and we'll be taking
those questions throughout the webinar
uh so yeah
and let's start with uh careers in
digital marketing
when you see digital marketing is the
backbone of racial economy how do you
think we have gotten to this point uh
where it has become the digital ectomy
boom
yeah that's a really great question so
one of the things that happened
especially during the pandemic and US
everyone having to work from home is
digital transformation as far as digital
transformation is concerned a lot of
people consumers actually change the way
that they did business just in general
day to day they ordered groceries online
they ordered clothes online they sent
school supplies online one of the
examples I like to use is I have a a
Target that's not far from where I live
but I still order stuff online when I
can just drive there so the mindset set
has shifted now digital marketing always
was super important because it allowed
businesses to be able to have presence
without having to have a super large
budget especially especially if they
were small business so essentially this
is why there's such a uh demand for
digital marketing because Technologies
are changing people are getting into
Full Throttle they're not going back to
the way that they did business anymore
they're actually propelling and Jet
setting to this new way of life and so
essentially businesses need to respond
they need to start to create
personalized experiences and this is
where we do that in careers in digital
marketing
uh that's that's a really good answer I
must say uh what do you think like uh we
have gotten to this point uh where uh
there are like new things right every
time you need to stay up to date with
the skills in business marketing you
cannot just learn one thing right so uh
what do you suggest for folks who
actually are starting off or in a
mid-career change as well uh yes
yes absolutely so learning learning
learning um as long as I've been in this
industry I have never stopped learning
about this field I am constantly taking
different certifications different
um courses different things going to the
actual platform like Tick Tock Google
Pinterest Instagram whatever you want uh
to kind of hang your hat on in terms of
platform I always go to their live
workshops because this is one of those
areas where it is constantly changing it
is technology that fuels this industry
so there's always going to be an
evolution if you are brand new or
thinking about making a change the best
way is to basically get into
certification programs such as this one
now this one has more of a comprehensive
look the second thing that you should do
is you need to figure out what part of
digital marketing that you would like to
really focus on I like to like in
digital marketing to almost like the
medical profession you have doctors who
are optometrists you have doctors who
are cardiologists you have all of these
different specializations right then you
have a generalist or a general practice
doctor that just kind of touches on
everything but even that person has to
Outsource out when he or she runs into
an issue of that they can't really solve
with their expertise so if you want to
become a generalist this particular
program actually helps to introduce you
to all of the disciplines and domains
that surround digital marketing but it
is also really good to become a
specialist because you want to have that
expertise or that subject matter
expertise that will center around a
specific discipline and you'll see if
you did a quick LinkedIn search you'll
see that a lot of that happens where
jobs or companies are looking for
someone that has a specific expertise in
one discipline in digital marketing and
this is what makes a lot of the
opportunities much more ride arranged
and much more wider in terms of how you
enter into the field
well that's that's really amazing thank
you so much uh for answering that
question uh so meanwhile we are talking
we actually are getting uh questions on
the Q a part as well so we'll be taking
that in some time just to let you know
that folks have already started putting
their questions uh related to digital
marketing career so uh as I can see
there are many career options in digital
marketing uh but can you take us to what
career paths people can follow on
digital marketing
yeah absolutely so just like I mentioned
before you have all of these different
disciplines right you have your digital
marketing manager who basically oversees
a lot of the separate disciplines that
you see listed in this infographic so
you have email marketing manager content
marketing manager social media
strategist advertising PPC
e-commerce now we have creative
functions so now they're dealing with
the creatives and creating like videos
ugc content all of that SEO analysts
website marketing managers now the
digital marketing manager is centered at
the top of this slide here because they
typically manage all of these
disciplines and they need to understand
how they work interconnectedly in order
for them to get that this is usually a
senior level position and they've
probably worked one or two of these
disciplines so again you have to just
decide like what do you truly enjoy
doing do you enjoy creating content you
enjoy writing things do we enjoy digital
marketing or are sorry digital
advertising or paid marketing what do
you really enjoy and what companies are
out there looking for the things that
you're passionate about so that you can
Custom Tailor your career based off of
that
um that's that's amazing but there's
always this dilemma right like where do
you get started right yep would you guys
guide us like where where do you get
started you know like how to deal with
this dilemma
yep so I see here that some folks are
saying yeah you know I like content
writing I like you know graphic design I
like all of these different things
really and truly anything that you do in
life as a career it should feel like
that you're playing right it should feel
like that you go to work every day you
enjoy you go to sleep with all these
things or your mind like I do I have
this big huge brain and it's a thousand
ideas in there so I know that if I'm
going to do
um any type of creative work that's
going to get my goat right so taking
like even career assessments to see what
you enjoy before you decide to embark on
a specialist path will work now again
this program is designed to introduce
you to all of the facets of digital
marketing so that when you leave the
program you can decide hey you know what
when we did that section on email
marketing I really and truly enjoyed
email marketing I think I want to pursue
that further or finally I love social
media I love hanging out on Instagram
and and Tick Tock so I would love to
just simply manage that portion of the
business so I would get yourself
introduced get yourself educated on the
different disciplines and domains and
then decide what really sticks out what
really resonates with you and then once
you figure out what resonates with you
by maybe taking some free assessments or
just internally you know reflecting on
what resonates with you then embark on
that journey to specialize
I think that answers that definitely uh
so uh like do you really meet these many
skills in order to uh you know crack
this into my marketing role
no
you will drive yourself crazy trying to
master everything the the saying in the
west is is master of many ruler of none
right you it's good to have a workable
knowledge but you do not have to know
every single thing about digital
marketing before you get into the field
absolutely not and there are programs in
in uh internships or online you know
projects that you can actually jump on
that you can actually test out with
those skills are when I do teach classes
here I oftentimes refer my students to
acadium acadium is kind of like a
freelance dashboard they don't pay for
these projects but it allows you to
explore can I see this for myself long
term and then if you do a great job then
the company may knock on your door and
say you know what you did really well
with this we really enjoy what you did
with our company would you be interested
in coming to work with us full-time so
again you can decide how and where to
trajectory of your career goals and go
from there I started with implementation
and execution and I said to myself in
2011 guys well 2012. said to myself then
by the time digital marketing catches on
I will be teaching it and here we are
teaching it so and and we are happy to
have you here yeah so essentially you
just really have to find what you're
truly passionate about what you enjoy
doing and then take that trajectory but
you do not have to know everything that
is not a requirement
that's that's the video honest answer I
must say that uh you know folks actually
spent half of their life working in a uh
you know somewhere uh and later on
realizing that you know this is not
something they like you know it was
something else they figure it out pretty
late uh this way of figuring it out what
you have told me right uh through
freelance projects it's really amazing
it saves you a lot of a decade I would
say you know more than a decade of work
you know which you'll be doing which you
might not like so that's that's a really
helpful answer I must say
yep absolutely awesome uh maybe let's
move on to a quick poll as you can see
on your screen
so uh we all have talked about the job
roles and we have talked about the
skills that you need so you all here
here because you need the digital
marketing certification uh you can see a
quick poll on your screen and uh the
options for those are like I could find
a program with a fully country as a
curriculum so if that is what is
stopping you can choose that uh I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure to
become
you know expert so you can choose the
second option you can also choose the
third one I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos uh the last one
is my work schedule won't allow me to
enough time for learning if that is
something you align with so you can see
quick goal uh on your screen if you're
join from your laptop from your mobile
you can just click an option and submit
it so you'll get to know basically what
exactly it's stopping you uh from taking
the digital marketing certification and
begin to help you out with your
questions you know queries which you
have uh and I can see we're getting
plenty questions in the Q a part as well
as well so keep that coming folks and
we'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
so a few folks who have not voted uh
please do go and vote for the poll you
see on your screen award basically is
stopping you from taking this digital
marketing certification so uh I'll be
closing the poll in five seconds
five four three two
one of we're getting a lot of answers in
the end okay let me just share the
result with your folks
as we can see uh what is stopping you
from taking the digital marketing
certification okay you can't find a
fully comprehensive program are
basically 35 percent of the folks I can
see half of the folks have said I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become a digital marketing
expert uh that is the biggest concern I
think they have and few of them have
said that I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos and I can say
few of them have said that my work
schedule wouldn't allow me to have
enough time for learning so that's great
thank you for your answers folks let's
move on to the next part
so we will talk about the Purdue
University program uh before I take you
through the Purdue University program uh
this program is a industry learning path
uh and in this program uh the you
actually get to work on comprehensive
curriculum which is industry aligned uh
and also the programs case studies and
hands-old project actually help you with
practical experience which actually
helps in boosting your job prospect and
we have an online live virtual classroom
with peers and instructor interaction so
why not it wanted to know uh the live
classroom virtual program which happens
uh how is it like is it interactive is
it boring like what kind of uh you know
classroom is this can you tell us a
little bit about the experience they
will be having in this classroom
yeah absolutely so one of the things
that I've always loved about the simply
learned program is definitely the
Hands-On projects the Hands-On things
that we do in class and when I am
instructing I always make a space for
the live classes to actually have that
Hands-On that group activity where we
can break out have these discussions and
really dive into the Hands-On part I
also come to the table with a lot of
experience so I bring in my examples of
things that I've actually run into the
tools that I actually use in my
day-to-day processes so that you all
will have an inside in this is something
that is not offered by like you know
your pre-recorded uh courses that some
of you guys mentioned you have a live
instructor that's answering your
questions in real time asking for
examples in real time and with all of
the projects that we have
um inside of each module you are able to
take those projects and present them to
potential employers and say Hey listen
I've been working on this certification
for six months these were the things
that we did inside of that class and
here's how I'm able to demonstrate my
expertise that I was able to acquire
also with having Harvard Business or
Purdue attached to a lot of that program
curriculum is going to bolster The
credibility that you have whenever you
are moving forward in pursuing your
career after getting your certification
so these certifications are now even
being looked for by employers like
they're just skipping decrees all
together I'm like hey do you have a meta
certification do you have a Google
analytics certification perfect please
come because in classes by the time you
if you think about it by the time you
complete your undergrad and it's nothing
against undergrad because I have an
undergrad degree and two masters by the
time you've completed it in undergrad
the technology has already changed
this program allows you to be able to
see what's happening in real time and
then set you on a path of this is how
you continuously refresh your knowledge
stay on top of the changes so that you
can be a successful professional
uh that explains it well uh also like
the program duration of this program is
six months and I can see that you just
need to give five to ten hours per week
is that really possible like how much
effort would you usually need to put in
in order to achieve that productivity
yeah so um the classes are typically in
the evenings on the weekends the only
problem uh that a lot of people face
with this is that you know is the cut or
the question that I get a lot is is the
class entertaining because this is a
night and weekend thing or how does this
work or we typically meet two times a
week for the live instruction and then
you have the autonomy of when you want
to complete your your uh projects that
you have that are due on that class uh
basis in the meantime when we do meet on
the weekends I am there as a guide to
walk you through what you need to be
looking for kind of looking over those
areas to tell you this is what you need
to improve this is what you need to take
out and so on and so forth but most of
the students that have successfully
completed this program did not find any
issues with the five to ten hour
commitment and in fact as you can see
I'm very animated I try to make them as
interesting as possible because I know
you guys are up until like 12 a.m in the
morning depending on where you are in
the world so these are some of those
areas that you know you really want to
think about when you're thinking about
any certification program that you want
to participate in your time commitment
to be in class is five to ten hours but
you may have a little bit of extra time
that you have to commit outside of the
times that we meet just to complete your
projects
awesome I think that makes sense thank
you so much uh for helping us with that
great uh so in this program what exactly
you'll be getting out of this program
you'll be getting a new postgraduate
certificate
has already explained how important it
is to have that per University tag on
your certificate uh while applying for
these jobs and you will also get to work
on Hands-On projects uh Capstone project
and master classes and EMAs with Purdue
and meta uh and also you'll be a part of
the Purdue Association membership which
basically is a simpler alumni Community
uh where you get to network with a lot
of folks from around the world and also
uh have a close knit circle of folks you
know who are studying with you so not
much different from an offline setting
but we try to make it possible you know
as much as possible for you folks to
interact with each other you know and
network with each other as possible
foreign
University Advantage uh has anyone heard
of Purdue before the session would love
to know on Jack yes or no
okay I if not let me take you through
the Purdue University Advantage okay I
can see folks responding yes some
obviouses some of know okay yes the best
Canadian someone has replied okay okay
okay fine fine maybe maybe let us take
you through that the advantage so Purdue
is a 150 year old University uh it has
been established by a land grant from
the state of Indiana and it is
consistently one of the top public
universities and has produced Nobel
Prize winners uh having party in
University like Bernadette said is a
very prestigious accomplishment
recognized worldwide uh well would you
like to tell us a little bit about per
University Advantage I think you have
mentioned that you know but a little bit
about it for folks to get an idea
yes so um when this program first
launched um I had the pleasure of
actually meeting the people who created
the curriculum
um for uh the simply learned partnership
and really and truly they wanted to
create this program with you in mind
thinking as someone that's breaking out
into the uh the the career field as a
beginner
um with having Purdue on your resume
like I said it is a prestigious
organization it's been around a very
long time and this is what you are
basically using as your own marketing
tool in order for you to be able to
Market your expertise you know a lot of
times when you start programs like this
accreditation is a concern sometimes who
you're aligned with is concerned
sometimes and really and truly with
having Purdue there's other programs out
there like you know the the Yale kind of
certification plan this one has a little
bit more legs just because of the
Partnerships and the vast Alumni network
um there's a huge amount of alumni that
you can connect with especially in the
digital marketing space in